the Marvel Cinematic Universe is always
expanding and evolving in one of its
newest additions is Captain America
Brave New World the film will follow Sam
Wilson aka the Falcon who took up the
mantle of Captain America at the end of
Avengers end game Gladiator was one of
the most epic and acclaimed movies of
2000 Gladiator 2 will be the
long-awaited sequel that will continue
the story of Maximus Decimus Meredith
the film will feature an amazing cast
including Denzel Washington Pedro Pascal
Joseph Quinn and Connie Nielsen the
Thunderbolts is an upcoming superhero
film based on the Marvel Comics team of
the same name featuring a group of
reformed villains who work for the
government Ryan Reynolds Deadpool is one
of the most popular and hilarious
superheroes ever and he's finally
joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
Deadpool 3. the film Will Follow The
Merc with a mouth as he interacts with
other MCU characters and breaks the
fourth wall like never before the film
will also feature Hugh Jackman as the
iconic character Wolverine Spider-Man
beyond the spider-verse is the third and
final chapter in the spider-verse
trilogy following Spider-Man into the
spider-verse and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse